who would you put uh on your Detroit
Mount Rushmore of rap
four slots blade icewood me
damn
they are Detroit Detroit only
blazewood me
as of right now I'm ladies with me
probably Ray
baby face Ray Ray
Vis this that's four P really got to be
on that [ __ ] too though
um
he's going crazy right now for sure for
sure for sure
do you think like a when you when you
see uh
the influence from Detroit like and you
hear it other places because I feel like
it's been happening a lot more recently
do you do you guys give a [ __ ] to try
and get like the recognition that like a
lot of [ __ ] is originating from there or
is it just like ah nah yeah we hear our
influence it's good to know it's
affecting everybody we thought they were
skipping overs but they really looking
at us at this point for sure people
people are still pop out with some of
the [ __ ] that come from the city and
they go bigger because they ain't see it
from us first yeah no you're right it's
crazy because like you said everyone's
getting signed uh you 42 Doug T grizzly
[ __ ] pza has been running it up with
Empire
shout out to uh boldy James who's doing
his thing on the on the boom bap [ __ ]
like him and Alchemist got some Classics
together so you know Detroit's going
crazy man